well next up we've got a real brain
twister follow me it's a catfishing
story that actually ends well oh this is
amazing let me explain the daily mail
reports a woman in florida named nicole
was almost scammed by a man that she met
on instagram named marcus marcus was
catfishing her using somebody else's
photo and then he started asking oh hi
okay i get it asking
that's the photo he's using he was
he started asking her for money so right
away she blocked him but then months
later she found pics of the same guy on
instagram except this time it was really
him
yeah the the picture was really the real
guy this time his name is alessandro
okay his uh his profession is working on
a yacht crew out of florida okay hi
alessandro
wow hi alessandro
so they connected on dms and you guys
the rest is history they're together can
you believe that the way she's looking
at him
they're in love
that is in love
good for them but i don't know i feel
like i'd be like 10 years into the
relationship and still be like i don't
know if i if this is really you oh
i didn't think about that angle no but
congratulations to alessandra because
you know you're hot if people are using
your photos to catfish other people
congratulations on your face and your
body
[Applause]
all right well this story um comes
courtesy of my mom actually yeah
um so spring is in the air the flowers
are in bloom and they give us a little
skippy in our step and now
science can confirm it
flowers have power
vogue reports a study found
that flowers make us happy now they
tested this on a group of 147 women each
woman got either a candle
a fruit basket or a beautiful floral
bouquet
and even three days later the flower
group felt happier than the rest but the
biggest confirmation according to
scientists is 100 of women who received
the flowers displayed a duchenne smile
which is quote the sole indicator of
true enjoyment it's the smile you can't
fake
science defines it as what happens when
the zygomatic major in the cheek tugs
the lips upwards and the
orbicularis oculi around the eyes
squeezes the corners into crow's feet
now this is an actual
phenomenon that happens that has
scientific names i can't pronounce
um
rossi
i would like to conduct my own test okay
oh oh okay let's try it
[Music]
[Applause]
look
oh
well can i try one look at this wait you
have what i have something for you
my obicularis oculi is
moving
my zygomatic major is going off the
chain and it's something i can't fake
[Music]
you